có quan ngày 1,5 năm, nhưng thông tin từ công an tình đồng này.
Đơn vị đã gió quy định tạm giữa hình sự đối với với vấn và dương,
xin năm 1,5 năm 1,5 năm 1,5 năm, tình đồng này để đưa trà làm só hình vì dưới.
Theo đó, gió có một tưởng với bà tê, xin năm 1,5 năm 1,5 năm 1,5 năm,
từ trước, nên vấn và dương này sình ý định rất thải mặt tê,
khoảng tháng 30,5 năm, nhưng hình khu trăm 20 tư,
giông lên mạng xa hội đặt mua xún và đặt để thực hiện thành ký.
Đến ngày 1,5 năm 2,5 năm, giông dùng xung bánh bệ cười kiến nhà bà tê,
khi bà tê ra một cửa thị vị dương bánh chung cổ,
mặc dù được đưa đi cấp cứu nhưng bà tê đã tử vong.
Sau khi tiếp nhận tình báo, phòng cảnh xa hình sự đã phối hợp với các lực lượng tình thành khám nghiệm hiện chương.
Phó động phong trào toàn xin tụ giá tội phạm và tập trung truyết sét,
bắt được đối tượng dương là thuộc phạm kè an.
Đồng thời thu dưới mục khẩu xung hơi nền bánh đạn chỉ,
gần sau trong bình đạn và nhiều bật trương khác liên quan đến gủ án,
hình cơ quan kè sất đều tra công an tình đồng này đang đều tra một giống và sư lý đối tượng theo phuy định của pháp lật.